So we're in the middle of a fierce debate
about how artificial intelligence
will change human society.
But have you thought
about how AI will transform
your relationship to the non-human world?
So these are bioacoustic recorders.
And I've spent years studying
how scientists use devices like this,
combined with AI,
to listen to the hidden sounds of nature
and decode non-human communication.
Hidden sounds,
because much acoustic
communication in nature
occurs in the high ultrasound,
above your hearing range,
or in the deep infrasound,
below your hearing range.
So I'm going to play a sound.
I want you to listen and try
to guess who or what this is.
(Chirping sound)
So that was a bat.
That was bat ultrasound,
recorded above your hearing range,
but slowed down so you could hear.
So that was an advertisement call
from the peak of the mating season.
Scientists can decode these calls,
so a sample bat to English translation
would be, and I quote,
"Pay attention.
I'm a Pipistrellus nathusii bat,
specifically male.
My name is X. I am landing here
and we share a common social identity
and common communication pool."
For a pickup line by a bat, not bad.
(Laughter)
So scientists have recorded millions
of bat vocalizations like this
and they've decoded many of them using AI.
And they've revealed
that bats have dialects
that they pass down
from one generation to the next,
and that baby bats
learn to speak just like you did,
by listening to the adults around them
and babbling back
until they speak adult bat.
So bats have far more complex
communication than we knew,
and they're only one of many examples.
Listen to this.
(Melodic chirping sounds)
So those are orcas who live right
here in the Salish Sea.
Scientists can decode individual
orca calls using AI
and they've revealed that orcas
also pass down their dialects
from one generation to the next.
So it turns out
that orcas and bats are not the only
creatures that make ultrasound.
Moths, mice, beetles, rats.
Even some of our smaller primate
cousins like this tarsier.
At the other end, in the deep infrasound,
elephants and whales,
tigers and some birds make sound.
So when we first learned about these
secret sounds of the world,
we're often surprised
because humans tend to believe
that what we cannot perceive
does not exist.
And so we miss a lot.
One of my favorite examples
is this peacock.
So to you, this looks
like a visual mating display.
And it is.
But this peacock is also making
very loud infrasound with its tail,
which you cannot hear,
but female peahens can.
And it is an important factor
in their mating decisions.
So this peacock is giving a rock concert.
(Laughter)
Now, we have lived
with peacocks for millennia,
but we only just figured this out.
Scientists also used to think
that turtles were voiceless
and mother turtles abandoned their nests
after laying their eggs.
But we've just discovered
that baby Amazonian turtles
communicate through their shells
before they hatch
to coordinate the moment of their birth
and then follow their mother's calls
to safety in the water.
Even creatures without ears
are exquisitely sensitive to sound.
So this is a coral larva.
When coral larvae are born,
usually at a mass spawning event
a few days after the full moon,
they wash out to sea.
So scientists used to think
that these little larvae,
these tiny dots that you see here,
were helpless, randomly pushed around
by wind and waves and currents.
But it turns out that coral larvae
are acoustically attuned.
They can hear the sounds of healthy reefs.
They can hear the sound
of their home reef, their mother reef,
and they swim back home
across miles of open ocean.
So these are tiny creatures
with no central nervous system.
But we think they do that with these hairs
that you see on the outside
of their bodies.
They're a lot like the hairs
inside your ears
that are enabling you
to listen to me right now,
so you can think of a coral larva
a little bit like an inside-out ear,
except that its sense of hearing
is profoundly more sensitive than your own
because they hear
with their entire bodies.
Even our planet makes sound.
Volcanoes, earthquakes sound so low
and strong and powerful,
they travel very far,
passing through soil and stone
and even solid walls.
Listen to this hydrothermal vent
deep under the ocean.
(Deep, rhythmic hum)
So in nature, sound is everywhere
and silence is an illusion.
So scientists are also listening
to the vast extent
of interspecies communication.
So this bat is using ultrasound
to hunt this moth.
Its echolocation beam
is locked onto its prey,
but the moth is also emitting ultrasound.
It's jamming the bat sonar
in an attempt to escape.
This plant is also emitting ultrasound,
which varies depending on its condition.
Scientists have trained an algorithm
to listen to this plant.
Simply by listening
it can detect with about 70
percent accuracy
whether the plant is healthy,
dehydrated or injured.
So this is peer-reviewed
research, by the way.
So we cannot hear these sounds,
but we think many insects can.
Does this mean that humans
could use digital tech
to one day communicate
with other species?
Well, some scientists think so
and they're using machine learning to try
to decode the acoustics of other species.
So there are teams of computer scientists
and linguists and biologists
working on decoding
sperm whale bioacoustics.
They're also building entire dictionaries.
So there's an elephant dictionary
with thousands of sounds.
Elephants, for example,
have a specific signal for honeybee.
So I'd love to share just one
of these sounds with you.
It was recorded at a moment
of great joy and celebration,
the birth of a new baby.
(Elephant roaring)
(Applause)
So the further we listen
across the tree of life,
the more complex interspecies
communication would be.
Listen to this honeybee.
(Honeybee buzzing)
Now listen to this honeybee queen.
(Queen bee tooting)
So you thought you knew
what honeybees sounded like. OK.
Honeybee communication
is incredibly complex.
It's acoustic, positional,
spatial, vibrational.
The queen has her own signals.
So scientists are encoding
these signals into robots.
This robot is attempting,
but not succeeding,
to communicate with the hive.
The bees mostly ignore or attack it.
But one day, we hope,
the inventors hope, that this robot
will communicate well enough
to allow scientists to monitor
the health of the hive.
Now, would that be a good thing?
Some believe that interspecies
communication would help foster respect
and empathy for nature,
others believe that it is profoundly
disrespectful and unethical
to eavesdrop and engage in this way.
And there could be a really big downside.
Listen to this robin.
(Bird chirping)
So that was not actually a robin.
That was a deepfake
created by an artist,
Daisy Ginsberg, using AI.
Clever, beautiful.
But think of the potential for misuse
by hunters or poachers.
Interspecies communication
needs strong ethical guardrails.
And anyway, maybe it's a bit
self-centered to think
other species would even want
to communicate with us.
(Laughter)
So what if we were to use bioacoustics
for something of immediate
practical value,
like doing something
about our massive biodiversity crisis?
Let's go back to the coral reefs.
Listen to this healthy reef sound.
(Chirping, croaking and sizzling sounds)
Pretty lively, right?
But coral reefs are disappearing.
If you were to go
to most coral reefs today,
you'd hear something like this.
(Staticky sound)
It's like a ghost town of the sea.
When we lose species, we lose voices.
When we lose landscapes,
we also lose soundscapes.
There is a ray of hope.
The healthy reef sounds
that you just heard
can be used to regenerate coral reefs.
Scientists are doing this.
It's a bit like music therapy for nature.
So this is not going to solve
all the problems coral reefs face,
notably climate change.
But if we can address the massive
epidemic of noise pollution
that is harming
and killing marine creatures,
we could use bioacoustics
to restore some biodiversity.
Bioacoustics could also help
protect animals on the move.
So this baby whale was killed by a ship.
Tragically, this is a common cause
of death of North Atlantic right whales,
one of the most endangered
species in the world.
So to address this,
scientists are now launching
a new bioacoustics program
off the east coast of North America
to triangulate the locations of whales
and convey the information
to ships’ captains in real time.
The ships then have to slow down,
stop, move out of the way.
Not a single right whale has died
of a ship strike in this zone
since this program was launched.
(Applause)
So this may be the thing
that saves this species.
So think about it.
A few decades ago, we were harpooning
these whales nearly to extinction.
Today, we've invented a technology
that allows a community
of less than 400 whales,
simply by singing,
to guide the movements
of tens of thousands of ships
in a watershed that's home
to tens of millions of people.
One day, these whale lanes
may be everywhere in the oceans.
For the orcas who live here
in the Salish Sea,
this would be just in time
because there are only a few dozen left.
A final thought.
About 400 years ago,
the inventors of the microscope
were astonished to discover
the microbial world.
They had no idea their invention
would lead to the discovery of DNA
and the ability to manipulate
the code of life.
Around the same time,
the inventors of the telescope
were gazing up at the stars,
not knowing their invention would allow
humanity to look back in time
to the origins of the universe.
Optics decenters humanity
within the solar system,
within the cosmos.
Bioacoustics decenters humanity
within the tree of life.
Our commonality is greater than we knew.
Now today we're using bioacoustics
to protect species
and decode their communication,
but tomorrow, I believe,
we'll be using bioacoustics
combined with machine intelligence
to explore the frontiers
of biological intelligence.
Many biological intelligences
are very different than our own,
but they're no less worthy of exploration.
And maybe one day in a speculative future,
instead of a human here on stage,
maybe bioacoustics would enable
an orca to give a TED talk.
(Laughter)
Why not?
Sharing orca stories about dodging ships
and seismic blasts and human hunters,
stories about desperately seeking
the last remaining salmon,
stories about trying to survive
on this beautiful planet
in this crazy moment
in our era of untethered human creativity
and unprecedented environmental emergency.
Now those would be ideas worth spreading.
(Chirping sounds)
(Applause)